can you explain to me for people
listening
essentially the part of his case that
helped them justify
the two life sentences was saying that
he
solicited murders no it wasn't the case
in the case
uh it was somehow a part of it was
okay he was indicted in maryland
for that it was based on the material
provided by
a corrupt agent who is who has been in
prison
for the last six years i believe he just
was released
um so hey you know who had uh
you know who supposedly had this
conversation with an
anonymous chat with supposedly dread
pirate roberts
no proof it was frost whatsoever anyway
that was submitted to maryland that has
now been dismissed with prejudice it
never went to trial it was never
prosecuted
because there were two cases then there
was in new york where he was did go to
trial that was never um charged
the jury never ruled on it and it was
never part of his convictions he was not
convicted
of anything to do with violence
whatsoever or murder for hire or
planning any violence
so this was something that the
prosecutors
talked about that they indicted in
maryland and dropped
and of course the media you know picked
up on it
and it's become part of the story but um
there's no proof of that who is the
agent who is the agent that you said is
in prison now well i think he might have
just been let out but um carl
mark force is his name and this is all
covered in that same thing the silk road
the
real and untold story that's on our site
but
um uh in detail footnoted
but um yeah karl mark force there's
another corrupt agent who also had run
of the site they had full reign of sight
they could act like dread pirate roberts
they could um change chats they changed
evidence potentially
uh and um his name is sean bridges
and i believe he is still in prison
i'm pretty sure so these two agents and
the real kicker about these agents
is that they were not allowed to be
known to the jury so when our
when ross's lawyers were like we're
going to tell the jury that there are
these two agents they could change stuff
on the site they could act as
jed pirate roberts the judge shot it
down she would not allow the agents to
be known to the jury
so we i didn't even know about him until
two months later when it all came out in
the news
but by then we're also been convicted it
was too late
do you still have any contact with his
attorney
uh his trial attorney no trial attorney
his name is josh right
australia now and he was also the
attorney for the appeal but no i don't
now was he court appointed or did uh
ross hired
he was highly recommended and we hired
him
and what is his take on all of this what
is his
i don't know i mean he's he yeah oh no
he what he thinks well i mean obviously
he fought for ross he thought he should
be
should be released his thing was that
ross um
that's was set up and that someone else
was doing this
that he wasn't that he you know started
the site
yes and that's all again in
in that um piece on the on the pa on the
uh
website so he you know yeah he i mean
yeah he's his defense attorney he felt
like it was it was you know he was
railroaded
so what are you doing now with uh with
your website freeross.org
and uh just give me an example of of
uh kind of like what is your mission now
and what are you
doing with with the website trying to
inform people
and uh and be active and outspoken about
what's going on
well one of the main things on our
website is a petition that um
please anyone listening if you haven't
signed it please go to freerust.org and
sign the petition there's a big red
banner or you can go to freeross.org
slash petition and it'll go right to
change.org where
where it is and it's uh approaching 360
000 people
signed it um i haven't been on it lately
but i'm
you know it's if it's not there it's
close um
people uh you know hundreds you know
way over a quarter of a million people
think that ross should be committing the
sentence should be commuted
i have personally you know done a lot of
interviews
on media as well as attended many
conferences over the years
just spreading the word correcting the
narrative um
you know uh just
uh you know promoting raising funds
that's always
an issue because lawyers are very
expensive people
but you know and doing that and just
in general um keeping this alive
i i feared that ross would be forgotten
you know he's he's buried alive over
there
in the metal box essentially and it's
easy to forget
there's a lot going on in the world
right now and so a lot of my
intention is to keep people
you know keep let not let him be
forgotten
you know once he's out you want to
forget i'm fine but you know
it's like not not forget him and all the
other people i mean
he's he's not unique in having a
terrible sentence and a really
unjust cruel sentence there's
thousands and thousands of people that
are i mean i i believe there's 150
people with
um life sentences for marijuana well i i
know that ronald ross's friends
in florence the the place he was before
this
um is that is serving a life sentence
for marijuana
and um it's in colorado where on the
state level marijuana is legal and the
guy's serving life
it's just it's insane just insane
so it's
serving life for marijuana in colorado
yeah does ross talk talk about
what he wants to do if he ever has the
chance to
be a free man again they ever talk about
what he would do or
what sort of aspirations he has well he
said he will work for criminal justice
reform
because he's seen firsthand of course
for over seven years now
that how much reform is needed and he
knows the people personally and
you know so he said he would definitely
work for that
um i imagine it since he's doing
work in prison about different ways that
he can help people through his knowledge
of technology that'll continue to do
that
um like what you know like the paper i
was telling you about
he's got he's full of ideas you know but
i would say that it's he's still a very
much of a freedom
loving person he believes in that and um
so i would imagine that would be as it
continued to be his inspiration
but it but but all legal all legal he
seems like
he will never come near breaking the law
again
no i mean he seems like like someone who
can be
such an asset to society
i agree to the country i mean someone
that young that creative
i mean he has the potential to inspire
so many people to
to make the world a better place
with with what he can do with his with
his skill with his talent with his
knowledge
it's just it's such a shame
that this brutal system that
put him away for so long it's just such
a shame and it's so
depressing to think that people still
they the system still works like this to
this
very day and there's so many people that
are just
going to waste away and have given up on
ever getting i'm never getting out
yeah i mean people victimless crimes
quote unquote
where where this was you know no one was
forced no one was
hurt no one this is not right
you should you don't you don't do life
for that
you know it's it's yeah our country
our country's criminal justice system
has been weaponized against people
and it's very alarming really when you
think about it it's very
very concerning and it's become this
mass incarceration that is
huge money giant money all kinds of
people are making money off of it
both privately and and government is
and um it's but the taxpayers are
funding this thing
and it's it's billions of dollars so
it's just
it's horrible
you